[Music]
[Applause]
hello hello I heard that y'all actually
just ran into each other a few days ago
that's so funny did you know you were
both coming here
I did you did I think I mentioned it I
was very excited about it yeah I just
thought it was funny that you ran into
each other you're like I'll see you in a
few days yeah it's kind of like a campus
so we're just starting it's getting
smaller and smaller I like it the more
we go closer to that all right I like
your Club um well you were talking about
your daughter the last time that you
were here is she two now she's two years
old yeah yeah she's two years old is it
terrible twos or fun is it fun oh I
think it's inspirational too
I'm just like a very good answer PC
thank you so much yeah highly trained
yeah yeah that's what I'm known for uh
total control
um but yeah she's uh she's really
confident she climbs up everything sure
she was at a pool party this weekend and
started chanting her own name and made
everyone else do it what's her name her
name is Ida
I love
I love that she's like her own hype girl
that's awesome yeah I mean I was like I
wish I could be like that now yeah yeah
wait you were also raising chickens the
last time I saw dude how are the
chickens okay this is a weird thing to
say but they were a rental what yeah
because when I got the chickens I was
like I'll just be this kind of person
who's like hey I'm I'm earthy I have
chicken but really my husband was like
you're not gonna want these chickens for
very long and there was a guy near us we
live in Massachusetts most of the year
and he rents chickens kind of like why
not Memorial Day to Labor Day and um
yeah interesting we got rid of those
girls they um they were really weird
those hens were hard to handle okay
those hens were following my husband
around everywhere and I was like I
almost got a little bit jealous
like they didn't want to have anything
to do with me and they just followed my
husband around and then did you like
having eggs though that's kind of cool
here's the thing oh we're getting we're
getting like one egg every four days
what they're just were weird and they
slept on the top of their cool lazy
chickens yeah chickens pop them out
girls what the hell I want some eggs I
want some eggs yeah you probably had no
ticks in the bag right oh I wish I mean
not to Lazy chicken I know not to be a
bummer but yeah it's a got a big tick
problem in Massachusetts well the
Northeast yeah in Texas as well where
I'm from yeah yeah yeah yeah well have
you ever had any chickens I know
everybody's like chicken did you see I
just did yeah
have you ever had any like not odd
animals but farm animals or anything
like that other than like dog or cat
I've had a horse okay he was very
important to me I met him making a film
in Mexico I I we bonded we I had I
couldn't say goodbye so I had him sent
up from Durango to uh pasquarez to El
Paso he got on a FedEx and he flew him
to New York City a horse flew FedEx
that's the easiest way to get him there
we'll deliver everything correct yeah
they will and and he was a great
companion to my oldest son who has an
intellectual disability he's autistic
and so even if he didn't want to ride
you could give him a brush and a bucket
and you know they're both happy all
afternoon no it's very therapeutic they
do that all the time yeah yeah Equine
Therapy X absolutely yeah that's cool
well um congrats on the Oscar nomination
oh thank you yeah I just was looking at
well both of you are on him they're
nominated yeah it's awesome you're both
nominated so this is also for best
animated feature so tell us about the
movie and how it felt to get nominated
sure um the movie is called Marcel the
show with shoes on it's about a a
one-eyed shell who has two shoes there
he is
um and um it's directed by Dean
Fleischer camp and we wrote it together
with our friend Nick Paley and it's
about a little guy who um mysteriously
sort of at the start of the film at
least loses his family and meets a
documentarian who starts to kind of
Chronicle his story and then they get an
opportunity to perhaps find the family
and it's about that process of of
figuring out if you even want to go on
an adventure and I think it's very
lovely very close to the heart yeah and
finding out that we were nominated for
an Oscar
it was a it was a a trip yeah you're
like wait what yeah it really was
um I have nothing to compare it to it
was not even anything I've ever dreamed
of like I just always really wanted to
be an actor that was like that's
definitely good enough for me to just be
chosen to play a role and have a camera
you know like yeah on that and
um it was probably like a little past
four in the morning I was getting all
these texts on my phone and I knew it
was Oscar nomination day and I was like
kind of think someone would have called
you know I think these might be apology
texts like oh sorry it didn't happen
yeah maybe next time totally totally and
then um and so I was like man I kind of
rolled over in bed and then someone my
friend Liz who produced the film called
and said that we've been nominated for
an awesome that's so cool yeah that's so
cool so you pay tribute to your
grandmother's both of them right yes I
love that why was this important to you
you know my grandmothers are just like
the some of the closest relationships
I've ever experienced and it's wonderful
yeah it's it's lovely and my grandmother
Rochelle recently passed and um yeah
that was a really hard and um
the grandmother in the film is named
Nana Connie that's my other
grandmother's name she has a the
grandmother in the film has a beautiful
accent there she is
um she's played by Isabella Rossellini
who has a gorgeous accent and my
grandmother Rachelle was born in Havana
Cuba in 1930 and then moved to Paris in
about I don't know maybe 1933 or 34 and
our family is Jewish uh they basically
ran right into second world war she
became she was a holocaust Survivor she
had a gorgeous accent an incredible
outlook on life and that all went into
that character I think my father might
have described her as like an artist
without a genre just was like super cute
yeah yeah wow your family's magical I
think so okay yeah yeah that's nice okay
well we have a clip this is when Marcel
is about to leave home in search of his
family and he's getting his grandmother
prepared to live without him for a while
all right so you've got the book you've
got a little bit of a raisin which I
really don't think you're gonna finish
but you can go to town go to town also
you have two tips of look over here you
have two dips of water you got an LED
flashlight in case the power goes out
you just gotta step on it like this see
yeah whoa sorry little stand right in
front of it finally this is the sparkler
what you do is you light this end on
fire and then you step back this can act
as a flare all right what I need that's
if you need a signal for help and Dean's
Gonna Leave You his phone just in case
you know what now that I'm thinking
about it why don't we just put the
colander over you now if you want
all right how's that
you must let me out of here
just let me out of here
so Marcel the show with shoes on is
nominated for an Oscar for best animated
feature you can stream it now on demand
[Music]
[Applause]